hi I'm Christopher John Farley a senior
editor through Wall Street Journal I'm
here with Aretha Franklin the Queen of
Soul she's got a new album out called
Aretha Franklin sings the great diva
classics miss Franklin thanks for coming
to The Wall Street Journal well thank
you thank you for having me now your new
album is your highest debut of your
entire career on the Billboard charts I
heard that 72 how does it feel to have
such a high charting album at this stage
in your career absolutely wonderful whoa
and what do you think people are
responding to this album what made them
decide to you know to go there and buy
it well I don't know we've got some
great titles of things that mr. Davis
presented to me and gave me a list of of
the singers and the songs and I'm doing
people Streisand I'm doing midnight
train to Georgia Gladys doing I'm every
woman Chaka Khan
no one Alicia Keys I Will Survive Gloria
Gaynor I'm a survivor Destiny's Child so
where did the idea come from to have you
an established superstar take on the
songs of some other performers some of
them are new some of them who have been
around before and of Irish Christ and
what did this idea come from
it was mr. Davis the chairman the
Chairman's idea
the CEO of RCA as I said he brought the
list to me and the list of singers and
so on but it was great because I had
already bought some of these records and
enjoyed them so it was a natural he was
super now of course with today's singers
there's some issues with singing
sometimes a lot of use of auto-tune I'm
wondering as someone who's in a known
for her voice has such a reputation what
do you think of the use of auto-tune by
by some youngers what is auto-tune I
don't even know what auto-tune is it's a
kind of way of electronically adjusting
your voice so then some pitchy it
doesn't sound wrong it sounds like it's
getting the note right now that's
ridiculous that would be ridiculous
right after 50 years please so rolling
in the deep' by Adele obviously a
terrific young singer someone's very
contemporary
no tell me your thought process in
saying you know what I'm going to tackle
the Sun well is he rolling in the deep'
I liked it when I first heard it I liked
it I saw some of Adele's promo and a lot
of young kids were on the bus they were
singing it and they were having a really
really wild good time
rolling in the day you know because they
couldn't really sing but they were just
having such a good time I said you know
I like that melody and I like that song
so when Clive presented it to me said
absolutely have you heard back from
Adele's heard back from any dissenters
whose works you take on legal issue Keys
album victory
I don't know Adele and we haven't had
the occasion our pleasure to meet yet so
it's not heard back I haven't heard from
them to begin with now when you take on
someone else's song you know obviously
you know them for taking Oh taking on
respect you signature song a song that
Otis Redding wrote and at popularizing
before you yet it became yours since
your song you ever think that I'm gonna
take this song over are you trying to
top the performer that did it before you
know with singers it's a thing sometimes
where you hear a great song and you said
oh man I wish that I got that song first
you know so after it's been out a while
you have the opportunity to rerecord it
after a while you know after so many
years and then we don't own these songs
you know we anybody can sing a song we
don't own them now since your new album
is about divas I want to throw out a few
names of Deeds instead of get your
one-word reactions of get your
impression a very singer so when I say
that the name Adele what comes to mind
mm-hmm Young Saeng a good singer Alicia
Keys um young performer good writer
producer Taylor Swift okay great great
gowns beautiful gowns uh Whitney Houston
Whitney was a talent definitely a talent
she had a gift and Cissy's baby
and search engines Allah nicki minaj
nicki manaj hmm now I'm gonna pass on
that one
we're talking on election day and Barack
Obama you are big supporter of his he
famously sang in his inauguration he had
that great hat that went viral how do
you feel he's done now that he's in his
second term finishing it up how do you
feel looking back on his term how do you
feel he's done as well isn't it's really
not for me to say I do do you have much
contact with him now he's been in office
you plan to do anything you have the
kind of events with him know what kind
of steps you're taking to sort of get
over this is a famous fear of flying
yeah just is it famous hopefully it's
pretty thin a lot of people know that
you don't get out of here desensitizing
you know I did go to a fearless Flyers
class and you're to desensitize you go
you go through the same procedure that
you would if you were flying going to
the desk calling checking on a flight
any specific light you'd like to take
that kind of thing now back the album
you know of you saying that this these
songs made things but other divas when
you go into interpret a song to make it
yours
what is your creative process I mean
that you have this song in front of you
do you play it on the piano to see how
it feels and how do you go into a sauna
to make it your own
well I just like to live with a song how
do you do that how you live with a song
you just sit with a song you know you
you take your time and you listen to it
that's about it but I'm not gonna tell
you my trade secrets Chris no I'm not
after the Tracy's I'm after just the way
as an artist well my last right those
are traits it's pretty yes you know I
can share with me you know it you know
that internal you might go into singing
Chris I'm just kidding
you think you'll do a part two for this
album obviously this is an album to beg
for a sequel you've taken on some other
great divas song signature songs are
there more songs you'd want to add to
the list and maybe do another album like
this I don't know we'll see I don't know
it depends on what mr. Davis would like
to do and we'll talk about it
I'll approve half and he'll approve half
or we'll see now I saw that you and
Clive had a back and forth over Twitter
and one of the questions that one of the
answers you had was very interesting
were you mentioned that if you hadn't
become a singer you might have become
either a ballerina mm-hmm or a
registered nurse mm-hmm you tweeted that
out from your account
yes were you joking are those actually
things you were thinking about doing no
no listen I went to the Academy of
ballet over on the east side and when I
left New York going to Los Angeles when
the industry moved West I went to a few
classes at Stephan winters out there and
Arthur Mitchell and I are very good
friends
there was one ballet step that I that it
just really took me a hard time to learn
that step and it was so simple he just
showed it to me another way and like
within seconds I was doing it and it was
like Glee sod glissade pas de Bouree
assam play okay so simple you know
Arthur's he's a master
so really was it something you
considered early on your created
something yes that I loved doing I love
the belly and I did a ballet from mr.
Davis once um I loved it you wrote a
biography of herself with David Ritz
mm-hmm um he's recently that was 15 or
20 years ago now what what are you
referring from these roots and from
these roots is yes the book that I wrote
and he co-wrote right he's come up with
zone biography of you know he's come up
with a book of trash that's all that is
is the book of trash lies lies and more
lies and lies on top of lies that's all
that is what are you planning to do next
musically if you finish this album
you're making some appearances um what's
next on the table for you well let's see
hmm
we are talking about the biopic I was
gonna ask you about that yeah we're
talking about that what stage is that it
ran very very close to signature very
close on all three there are three deals
on the
now in the past you've talked about who
you think could play you in my own
mm-hmm who do you think right now
what's your feeling at who could play
Luther Franklin in a movie well there
are several people that we're
considering um that I'm considering
Audra McDonald is one she'd be great um
you know Audra's got a great voice and
she's Broadway oriented but she is an
actress the question where Audra is
concerned is whether or not she could
she could deal with with soul as I sing
it but she's an actress and so it would
be her job you know it would be her job
to meet that challenge and there is she
just won what an Tony for lady day so
it's possible it's very possible it
depends on how she feels about it and
then there is the possibility of
Jennifer Hudson and there is the
directors book names and faces that I'm
not aware of and don't know about and
then there is the possibility of someone
from the church maybe an unknown I've
heard you say that Jennifer Hudson is
one of your favorite singers but what
about her really attracts you into the
voice and her vocal delivery Jennifer
Hudson is a very good singer um she's
likable she's likable what if it's been
to hold up in the cuz you've been talked
with a movie for some time what is it
hold up for the movie not being made you
think that at some point that they were
there is no hold up but if you know
anything about negotiations you know
they can go on forever
yeah there's no hold of them well miss
Franklin thanks a lot for coming to The
Wall Street Journal thank you a pleasure
talking to you the album is Aretha
Franklin sings the great diva classics
thanks a lot thank you